[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
my name is captain jefferson kyle kidd
and i'm here tonight to bring the news
from across this great world of ours
so they pay you to tell stories i ain't
never heard of that as a thing a man can
do
it's not a rich man's occupation as you
can see
[Music]
hot stop stop i'm not gonna hurt you
do you understand english
friend
says your name is johanna leonberger
indians took you when they attack your
family six years prior
the mother of father and sister were
well they passed
she's got family down in castroville
captain why are you doing this
she needs to laugh and dream she needs
new memories
roads closed is that the law
it is now
captain you johanna
i do not have a clue as to the care of a
child
it's a photograph
that's my wife
you can certainly handle a horse that
there's a horse
[Music]
captain make no mistake
captain where it is she's that captive
out of wichita falls
what do you want how much you offer this
child is not for sale
ladies and gentlemen these are stories
of men and women
very much like you waiting for better
days to come
you can't have her i'm taking her home
[Music]
[Music]
you